[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen an diesem
Feiertag als erstes blicken wir auf die
Weihnachtsansprache des Papstes rund 70
000 Menschen kam dafür nach Angaben des
vatikanans zum Petersplatz in Rom Papst
franziskus sprach vor allem über die
bewaffneten auseinanders der wel und
rief eindringlich zum Frieden auf
Jennifer GKE
berichtet es ist ein Weihnachtsfest in
Kriegszeiten wieder einmal Papst
franziskus ruft zum Ende der Gewalt im
Heiligen Land auf seh sich nach dem Tag
des
Friedens der Tag komme bald in Israel
und Palästina wo der Krieg das Leben
dieser Völker erschüttert ich erneuere
meinen dringenden Appell für die
Freilassung derer die noch immer als
Geiseln festgehalten werden ich flehe
darum dass die Militäroperationen ein
Ende
nehmen eine politische Lösung für die
Region so sein Appell
und um aber nein zum Krieg zu sagen muss
man Nein zu den Waffen sagen wie kann
man von Frieden sprechen wenn Produktion
Verkauf und Handel von Waffen
zunehmen der 87-jährige erinnert auch an
andere Krisen wie im jeemen in Syrien
und der Ukraine zum Schluss spendet
Papst Franzis
und
erkreis für die Besucher ein wichtiger
Moment es ist eine Botschaft einer der
wichtigsten Personen die zeigen kann wie
wichtig Frieden
ist eine Botschaft des Fried
[Musik]
düstereniten daernden Kämpfe im Nahen
Osten hat Ägypten einen Plan vorgelegt
wie der Krieg beendet werden könnte die
Hamas lehnt ih Vorschlag jedoch ab und
auch die israelische Regierung hält
derzeit nichts von einer Waffenruhe die
Einzelheiten von Susanna
Santina für die Öffentlichkeit
überraschend hat premier Netanyahu heute
israelische Truppen in Gaza besucht das
ganze Land sei stolz auf sie so der
Premier und
bekräftigte allen die von uns wollen
dass wir aufhören zu kämpfen denen sage
ich nein wir kämpfen bis zum
Ende also bis die Hamas besiegt ist von
einer Waffenruhe weiter keine Rede es
wäre die erste Voraussetzung für den von
der ägyptischen Regierung
vorgeschlagenen dreistufenplan gewesen
auch die Hamas setzt die Kämpfe fort und
lehnte den Vorschlag heute direkt ab man
bleibe dabei erst ein Kriegsende dann
mögliche Verhandlungen Dutzende Tote
soll es durch israelische Luftangriffe
gestern auf mehrere Orte gegeben haben
in magasi im Zentrum Gaza große Trauer
zahlreiche Menschen werden
beigesetzt meine Schwester ihr Mann und
ihre zewei Kinder wurden getötet sie
waren zwei Wochen und 3 Jahre
alt im Parlament in Jerusalem hatte
Netanyahu heute einen schweren
Stand Angehörige der Geiseln werfen im
vor sich nicht ausreichend für die
Freilassung der entführten
einzusetzen in Serbien protestiert die
Opposition seit ten gegen die Ergebnisse
der Parlaments und Kommunalwahlen sie
wirft der Partei vom Präsident wusic
Betrug vor im Zentrum von Belgrad
blockierten Studierende aus Protest eine
Straße gestern abend hatten
demonstrierende versucht das Rathaus zu
stürmen die Polizei nahm mehr als 35
Menschen fest es gab dutzende
verletzte fast drei Wochen lang galt
Krem Kritiker Alexi navalni als
verschollen jetzt wurde er nach Angaben
seiner Sprecherin ausfindig gemacht und
zwar in einem Straflager im arktischen
Norden Russlands navalnis Anhänger
vermuten dass der Kremmel ihn gezielt
aus dem Licht der Öffentlichkeit
entfernt hat nachdem Putin angekündigt
hatte im März erneut als Präsident zu
kandidieren ich verstehe dass es
manchmal zu viel wird dass man am
liebsten vor der Wirklichkeit in Deckung
gehen möchte das sagte Bundespräsident
Steinmeier heute in seiner
Weihnachtsansprache und rief dazu auf
die Hof auf eine friedlichere Welt nicht
aufzugeben patriia wiedmeier hat
mehr die Welt habe sich von ihrer
dunklen Seite gezeigt viele Bürger
würden keine Nachrichten mehr anschauen
sich zurückziehen an genau diese wendet
sich der Bundespräsident will ihnen Mut
zu sprechen manche einer schaut
skeptisch auf Staat und Politik und
mancher hat Sorge vor der Zukunft wir
alle haben Sehnsucht nach einer
friedlicheren Welt ich habe sie auch und
ich ich finde wir dürfen sie nie
aufgeben von den Politikern müsse man
erwarten dass sie Antworten geben die
dem Land weiterhelfen Steinmeier
appelliert an alle im Bundestag
vertretenden demokratischen Parteien
zusammenzuarbeiten wo es um das
gemeinsame ganze gehhe zu den guten
Ratgebern gehören Mut und miteinander
dazu gehört alle im Blick zu behalten
egal wo und wie sie leben weiter kommen
wir immer nur gemeinsam
in Zeiten von Krieg und Terror will der
Bundespräsident trotz allem mit
Zuversicht ins neue Jahr schauen eine
weitere Botschaft auss Schloss belvu im
täglichen gegeneinander dürfe keine
Kraft mehr verschwendet werden gemeint
damit wohl auch die
ampelkoalitionäre und die ganze
Ansprache des Bundespräsidenten gibt es
gleich nach dieser Sendung hier im
ZDF intensive Regenfälle und Tauwetter
haben an vielen Flüssen in Deutschland
zu Hochwasser geführt in Heringen in
Thüringen wurde ein ganzer Ortsteil mit
etwa 400 Menschen in Sicherheit gebracht
bei Hildburghausen ist eine Talsperre
fast gefüllt die Feuerwehr versucht mit
einem sandsackdamm ein Ort zu schützen
auch in Sachsen SachsenAnhalt und
Niedersachsen stehen Straßen unter
Wasser und der Deutsche Wetterdienst
warnt vor starkem Tauwetter im
Erzgebirge sowie vor ergebigen
Dauerregen in Teilen Niedersachsens und
nordrheinwestfalens morgen wird es vor
im Norden und in der Mitte etwas regnen
sonst bleibt es meist trocken besonders
im Süden scheint auch die Sonne bei
einem teilstarken Westwind werden 7 bis
11°
erreicht die nächsten Nachrichten sehen
Sie bei uns um 23:20 Uhr ein schönen
Abend
[Musik]
noch